>> James, you know,
I really like how we're getting immediate visual results from our code.
>> JavaScript's fun like that.
It runs natively in the browser.
And it allows us to run an inspector code very easily.
That's something you should be doing when you're starting out as a developer.
>> Yeah, it really is.
By the way, why are we in your GitHub again?
>> Because this is where I store my code and
I wanted to get the students thinking about what it means to save their data.
>> Like other programming languages,
JavaScript gives us a way of saving data in the form of variables.
The syntax looks like this.
Var, variable name equals some valuable.
To declare a new variable you begin with the keyword var,
regardless of the data type your saving.
In the example here,
we're creating a variable called firstName in assigning it the string james.
The string comes in closing quotes.
Notice that saving variables is slightly different than Python,
which doesn't require a key word like var.
But otherwise, works the same.
>> Good point.
But otherwise, saving variables in Python and JavaScript are pretty similar.
Numbers in JavaScript don't need quotes and there's no need to
worry about any of the nuances between floating point numbers and
integers, because all numbers are saved 64 bit floating point.
>> Later on we'll see that arrays, functions and
even objects use the same var syntax.
Let us see if our variables were actually saved.
I'm going to add console.log(firstName).
Save this file and reload the website.
Opening up the console to see if it shows up.
>> And there it is.
I like that strategy.
The browser opens up a script with console.log in it.
It'll print whatever information it receives to the browser console.
>> Yep.
It's a useful trick for debugging code.